damn it
hello holly whoa
what are you doing you don't uh you
don't have to do that i mean we have
already put together chairs
that's how we buy them actually trying
to adjust the lumbar support on toby's
chair and
that made this up down lever thing not
work and then i took the whole chair
apart and that
is the story of me on the floor it's
pretty good right
i'm gonna tell the movie rights and the
sequel woman stands at desk and works so
i have no idea how you how you sit like
that
yoga sit on floor and put together a
chair we will
yoda um
pass curvy metal piece you will
so are you in town this weekend because
i'm not i'm not i'm not going to be in
town
going out of town oh so you can't make
my orgy
kidding i'm kidding
actually
love it yeah
i did it what'd you do
i talked to her holly just pleasantries
nothing
you know not like do you want kids or
religion or what side of the bed you
want hey
i can take either side of the bed at
this point wow okay how'd that feel
it was hard i wanted to kiss her i'm so
glad you did
laying a base laying a base there you go
there's plenty of bees laying left right
hey
hey hi wasn't sure you're gonna come
well i got very curious when you only
left me one voicemail message instead of
your usual 20.
i'm trying to be a little less intense
and a little more considerate
here have a seat but only if you want to
okay
i want to
i never listened to what you wanted or
how you wanted us to be when things
ended between us i just decided what i
wanted
and i got upset when you didn't want the
same thing
i know that's not fair and i'm very
sorry
well thank you i appreciate that if you
don't want to have any more contact with
me
i finally understand i i don't want that
really but i just think it's for the
best
okay okay
there is another option
we could just say screw it and do this
thing for real
what i miss you like crazy i think about
you all the time
i want to be with you so let's just say
screw it
oh we would have to tell chris you could
turn into a scandal it could hurt your
campaign i mean how
would you imagine we do this i don't
know but i
i know how i feel and i want to be with
you
but i'm done steamrolling people
this is how i feel how do you feel
i gotta hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony
it wasn't difficult i simply said what i
wish had been said when kevin and i got
married
oh well then i never would have heard
your hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing but all
this does make me think i might enjoy a
more
festive expression of our commitment to
one another are you suggesting we
hold an honest-to-goodness wedding
nothing too elaborate
we're not the kardashian west's after
all they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know
they were answers on jeopardy i think
you mean questions
[Laughter]
you guys are fun i don't want you to go
back to london
just remember every time you look up at
the moon i too
will be looking at a moon not the same
moon obviously that's impossible
you gotta forget about all the other
stuff you gotta forget about logic
and fear and doubt you just gotta do
everything you can to get to the one
woman who's gonna make all this worth
at the end of the day you gotta jump
[Music]
you love angela dwight
i think you always have
you're a good assistant jim not as good
as you
that's very true
get the hell out of here you got it
i was just checking out my presence
[Music]
this is an amazing gift because it comes
with bonus gifts
look inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god the yearbook pictures
incredibles is this the boggle timer i
didn't think you're going to get that
one
i really do oh no this is like the best
present ever
okay wait what is this
the mini golf mentality like three years
ago
[Music]
you watched it yeah
well well i can guess you're ready for
this
what's that it's from the teapot
everything you'll ever need to know is
in that note
not enough for me you are
everything
thank you
hey man what's up
hot diggity dog oh no
now the thing i said right after we
kissed will always be hot diggity dog
whatever it was an honest reaction i
stand by it i don't want you to take
this the wrong way
but you got to calm the f train down
you're gonna ace this test
you think that because you love me and
love has made you dumb i disagree if
anything love has made me smarter
remember last week when i boiled that
egg that was big i was really proud of
you
thank you oh
pull over dwight
move to the side
i love you and i don't care that
philip's not my son
i will raise a hundred children with a
hundred of your lovers if it means i can
be with you
can you put that down this expresses how
loudly i love you it's too loud
this is a ring taken from the buttocks
of my grandmother
put there by the gangster patriarch of
the coors dynasty
melted in a foundry run by mennonites
okay
yes yes i will
i love you i love you
and i lied to you what philip's your son
what why would you say that i just
needed you to want to marry me
because you wanted to marry me
get out i'm a dad you're a dog
you